thank you thank you so uh
i have good news and bad news the good
news is you'll be seeing a brand new
talk never seen before
and the bad news is the same okay
um maybe okay
so are we talking about sequence
problems
and some hardness for these problems
these will be some problems that are
solvable in quadratic time and will give
some
reason why we can't really improve on
them
based on strong eth and in particular
the orthogonal vectors conjecture okay
so let me first define some sort of
uh sequence walk problems oh oh
let me do this first okay so first i'm
going to tell you what the plan is the
plan is i'm going to define a bunch of
these problems
so you can see what we're studying and
the particular problems i'll mention are
for shade distance edit distance dynamic
time warping and the longest common
subsequence problem
and then i will also give you some
view on how to get algorithms for these
problems
and then we'll talk about
conditional lower bounds but i'll
only focus on one example and it itself
is already pretty complicated
we're not that complicated but it
requires more work than the
reductions we've seen so far and
and also when you see the proof you sort
of have some idea of how the other
proofs go
so it's it's it's a good example of
of these reductions okay
so let me start with the sequence
problems and the first thing i'll do
is i'm going to talk about frechet and
dynamic time warping
and they have one thing in common and
they are sequence
walk problems so you're given two
sequences
okay and the sequences let's say are
sequences of some points and there's
some distance measured between points
uh and this distance measure may depend
on the problem
and now you want to have a you want to
walk
on these two sequences one at a time and
the walk looks like this
you start at p1 and q1 in the beginning
in a per in some particular step you're
at pi and qi let's say p3 and qt
uh q2 you're there and now at this
in the next step you have to decide
where to go and there's only
three options you're always walking to
the right
the first option is you only go right on
sequence p
so like this okay the second
option is you go right only in sequence
q
so you go there and the third option is
you walk on both of them
okay so these are the types of walks
we're exploring we're given two
sequences of points and we're exploring
blocks of this form
and among these walks we're going to
optimize some measure
okay so the measure we are optimizing
depends on the problem but in particular
it's some function
of the distance between the the points
in each step of the walk
and frechet and dynamic time warping
have different functions
all right so hopefully this is clear now
i can define
the next two problems so the fresher
distance
uh is the dog walking distance so if
you're a dog lover
maybe you want to take your dog for a
walk and
to be nice to other people you want to
have a leash
okay so now the dog has some trajectory
it wants to traverse and you have a
trajectory you want to traverse let's
say you want to get coffee
all right but you're sort of limited by
the length of your leash
and let's say leashes are expensive for
some reason and you want to
minimize the length of the leash so
let's say
and now you're doing this walk where at
each step both of you
decide whether to go along your
trajectory
and among all these choices of walks you
want to minimize the maximum distance
between you and your
your dog which is the length of the
leash so you want to
minimize the maximum overall possible
choices of
ways to traverse the trajectories so
this is uh
the frechet distance it has a kind of
nasty looking definition
but what i said makes sense so in the
continuous world
what you're given is two curves
let's say on the plane they take points
uh from the unit interval between zero
and one and
into the plane and now f is some set of
monotone functions that say
basically in each point in time between
0 and 1
where on each curve you are at and now
the distance between the two curves
under the fresh air measure is the
minimum overall traversals
of the curves which are these functions
of the maximum distance
at any point in time so this is the
continuous version
now we kind of live in a discrete world
so we discretize it
and the way it's typically discretized
is now
the curves don't go from zero one they
go from the points one to n
and this just basically means time one
i'm here time to
here anyway so uh and now this converts
the problem
from curves into problems on sequences
now you have sequences of points in the
plane and the traversals
are now these functions non-decreasing
functions from the time interval into
your
into your points on the curve okay and
it becomes exactly this walk
sequence walk problem you're trying to
find a walk
a long p and q that minimizes the
maximum
distance between
you know the points where you're at each
step
okay so this is for shared distance it's
very widely studied
and it has a pretty simple algorithm
which i'll describe on the slide
so here here's again the definition you
have these
uh sets of functions that describe
the ways you can walk along the curves
and
you want to minimize overall possible
choices of traversals of both the curves
the maximum distance and you can solve
this with dynamic programming
you define some table aij that says what
is the actual
fresh aid distance for the for the sub
subsequence from one to i and the
subsequence from one to j
and then i sort of naturally define it
as the maximum
of the distance so at points i and j and
the minimum
of uh whether you you actually walked
along
p only walked along q only in the
previous step or you walked along both
of them
okay so this is some very simple dynamic
programming algorithm
it runs in n squared time because we
have endpoints in all
both of the sequences and
as usual for this boot camp
you can get some tiny improvements so
there's a log
and roughly improvement
kind of reason actually and there's many
many algorithms for some special cases
and variants but
basically n squared is where we act
again
okay
dynamic time warping is another sequence
walk problem
what is it now you have two sequences of
points of length in
uh and uh it's basically you find a walk
along the sequences x and y
the minimize is the sum of the distances
or each step
so instead of taking the maximum
distance that it worked with crochet now
you're taking all the sums
and it's often just defined with this
which is
the dynamic programming algorithm
and it has a lot of applications in
speech processing for example you want
to
someone says a word you want to know how
what they're actually saying so
this this problem is used to figure this
out
again the simple dynamic programming
algorithm is that and it's
very very similar to the fresher one
where you just replace the max with a
plus
all right so so these are the sequence
walk problems i'll
i'll talk about two other problems that
are that can also be used
as yeah is there a faster album for this
dynamic
time working um i couldn't find even a
poly logarithmic
improvement but i suspect there should
be one i haven't tried
it's a good question so whether n
squared is actually the currently best
probably not but i couldn't find i
couldn't find any literature
if you're allowed to go back uh probably
the reductions no longer work but i
haven't talked
about that it's a good question yeah
so for crochet distance this is also one
variant that is
studied and you can also show hardness
oh you can okay
and square time for computing exactly
oh good okay is that in your paper
okay all right you could thanks
just have the points be getting closer
and closer together
as time goes by so it's never worthwhile
to go backwards
oh yeah yeah probably you probably have
a reduction like that
okay so the next
two problems won't immediately look like
sequence walk problems but they're still
you can formulate them in that way
so the first one is something a lot of
us teach in our algorithms courses
it's the longest common subsequence
problem
so given n sequences of letters
and you want to to find a sequence
that's a subsequence of both of them
and it has maximum length so let's take
these two words meaning and matching i
want
m a i n g is a subsequence of this one i
know this one
and it happens to be the one of maximum
length and this is the longest common
subsequence of these two words
so this problem has a lot of
applications
it has applications to computational
biology it's used in spell checkers
and also
solving this problem is at the basis of
this diff utility in unix and there's a
lot of a lot of applications
so okay again
because it's uh essentially defined in a
similar way to the previous two problems
you can differ you can have a dynamic
programming algorithm you can look at
what the best solution is for sequences
up to i and up to j
and now depending on whether
s i and t j are the same you get you add
the one
one plus this and otherwise you don't so
okay so this is this is this and you
again you can get some
improvements a little small improvements
over n squared but we don't know how to
do much better
okay so then we have a slight
variant on this which is the edit
distance problem
which is even more studied so
here we're given again two sequences of
symbols of length n
and now you want to define the distance
between these sequences
is the minimum number of symbol
insertions
deletions and substitutions
so here's an example if we take the same
two words as before meaning in matching
you can transform one to the other in
the following way
we take meaning then we insert a in
front of e
now it becomes this bizarre word then we
transform the e
into a t after that
we make a into a c and then
n into h and this this concludes the
transformation and the number of changes
you make
is four so each one of the insertion
deletion and substitution they
have a cost of one and so you want to
find the minimum way to get from one
word to another
this way longest common subsequence is
the same as at the distance when you
disallow
symbol substitutions so this is the only
difference between the two problems
and insertions as well right oh you can
um yeah it depends on whether you allow
it and
one string or the other anyway
uh okay sorry it's yeah it's fine
um okay
again we have a dynamic programming
algorithm
basically following the definition that
runs in n squared time
you can again improve it by a log factor
and there's thousands of algorithms for
special cases
i thank peodrindick for some of these
slides
and and then there's this very very
intriguing
approximation scheme which gets a poly
logarithmic approximation
in near linear time so n to the one plus
epsilon
time it's not what we really want we
would love to have something
that gives you a fixed logarithm or
maybe
like a one plus epsilon approximation
but
we don't have any way of ruling this out
and we don't have techniques
to do this
anyway so there's that said at the
distance
okay so yeah of any hardness of
approximation for uh
for the problem not for at the distance
there's no hardness of approximation for
any distance that we know yet we've been
trying but
it just as you see the reductions are
they produce an instance of checking
whether the
distance is some quantity or at least
the quantity plus one
and getting a gap seems difficult with
the current techniques
so okay so i define a bunch of these
problems you notice some of them are
very similar
and what do they have in common they're
all very widely used matrix
metrics they're used all over the place
and very practically motivated
they have simple dynamic programming
algorithms basically
you look at the definition and it just
happens
we have absolutely no idea if you can do
much better than n squared
people have explored uh proving
threesome hardness for these problems
for years and have not succeeded
and so perhaps they're hard under the
orthogonal vectors conjecture
starting with th because this is a
different problem maybe you can get
reductions from it even though from
threesome it has proven to be
challenging
okay and okay so
this concludes the introduction of this
and now i will take some more questions
and then i'll move to
giving you some proof
so for this time warping distance since
you can either have
one walk two or both and you some every
step
it seems that the sequences where both
walk all the time
somehow i have an advantage
that's a good question uh
well it sort of depends on how what the
diff distances are
sometimes it makes sense if you have
something that's very
cheap compared to some others to stay
there until
something changes
you can't you can't gain by just waiting
well you're right sum is different from
maxwell
okay good
so i will just give a very quick
reminder
what the orthogonal vectors conjecture
was for people who maybe didn't see my
previous talks
i'm going to say so you have a set of
vectors
that all have coordinates in 0 1
to the d is some
something that you can think of as
slightly super logarithmic or
maybe it's logarithmic but a little bit
more the number of vectors is
n and we're asking if there's two of
them that are orthogonal
so whenever one is uh one of them has a
one some coordinate the other one has to
have a zero
you can trivially solve it in n squared
times d
time just befo by following the
definition
and uh recently uh ryan
amir and ho chang got this algorithm
that improved on
n squared whenever but the but
the improvement depends on how far away
d
is from log n so the further away you
get the closer
this goes to n squared so
okay uh the conjecture is that this
problem cannot be
solved in into the two minus epsilon
time for any constant epsilon and
dependence that this polynomial in the
dimension
and as we saw in previous talks this
conjecture is implied by the strong
exponential time hypothesis
so uh so
we will just uh focus on the orthogonal
vectors problem we won't be talking
about structure th at all
and now all the reductions are the
single reduction i'm sure you will be
assuming i have a set of vectors uh n of
them
and they have very small dimension d i'm
not going to fix d
to be log n it will be d and then uh
i will i'll create instances of the
sequence problems from this
so here's a theorem or
a union of theorems that we know about
these sequence problems
we know that unless the orthogonal
vectors conjecture fails
there's no truly subquadratic algorithm
for anyone of any distance dynamic time
warping for shade distance and longest
common subsequence
so um the first of these results with
the was the first shade distance results
by
uh bringman and who's right there and
uh the edit distance result was
from by arthur bakkers and peoriantech
and then uh our tours
and amir and i we got this longest
common subsequence resulting
independently of
us uh bringman and kenneman also got
that
so this is how things progress here so
there was this paper that i had with
amir
and oren weirman and we were considering
some
slightly harder looking sequence
problems and that's
and we showed that they're strong at th
heart and i think that
this sort of made us think a little bit
more about these problems and
we got somewhere all right
so what was the approach approaches
actually it's not going to be we're only
going to create
a single instance of the sequence
problems
we're going to take orthogonal vectors
and just reduce it
to two sequences we take the set of
vectors
and out of all these vectors we can
create a single sequence x
and again we created a single sequence y
the nice property of x and y is that
their lengths
are only n times polynomial in the
dimension
so when d is poly logarithmic this is
actually roughly n you know and same
here
so now what we want is that
after we do this the distance between x
and y depending on the problem that we
consider
will be small if if
they were talking if there are two
orthogonal vectors and it's large
otherwise and then
we also want the construction time to be
fast and we actually achieve this with
a construction time of end times paulie
d
and and finally uh the way we do the way
we create these sequences
involves a bunch of gadgets and what we
we end up doing is
for every zero or one in in the vectors
we have to create a gadget that
transforms it into subsequences
into small sequences and these these
gadgets have to interact in a nice way
out of the coordinate gadgets we make
vector gadgets and now the vectors have
to interact in the right way
so whenever whenever they're orthogonal
they have to have very small distance
whenever they're not orthogonal they
have to be far away
and finally we take these vector gauges
and make the
big sequence out of them and we still
have to preserve this property that
whenever there is orthogonal vectors the
distance is actually small and when
there isn't one it's big
so each of these steps take some careful
combinatorial arguments and you have to
be
careful because the way you you can walk
on these sequences can be very
very diverse so you have to it's a
delicate argument but you'll see in a
bit
so after this overview i'll give i'll
start talking about the hardness of
longest common subsequence so if you
have any questions
please ask
the fact that the longest common
subsequence
is
it doesn't mean it yeah just because it
looks simply doesn't mean that
so actually having substitutions make
the makes the problem different and you
have to have different reductions to
show hardness but
they're still similar in spirit so
okay so just a disclaimer
i won't be proving much i'll just sort
of give you the ideas
and i'll show you the full construction
so carl and marvin they got an
independent proof which is different
from ours you can check it out too
okay so what's the idea
well i have a lot of slides that say
idea because it's
okay but uh okay so the first the first
thing we'll do
is just assume that we already have some
really really nice vector gadgets
so what does this mean we have some way
from every every vector in our
set of vectors there's a way to
construct a small sequence
f and a small sequence g and it has this
nice property
that when i take the two different
vectors s i and sj
and i look at the longest common
subsequence of
f of s i and g of sj
it will be exactly some quantity beta if
they're not orthogonal and it will be
something bigger than beta otherwise
it will be at least better plus one so
suppose we somehow did this
it will require a bunch of work too but
suppose we had this
it will maybe will make our life simpler
okay now i'll just say i'll add this
vector s sub zero
to to my set which will be the vector
of all ones this vector is not
orthogonal to anything so
it doesn't change my my problem very
much
okay so now i'll try to attempt to allow
to put all of these little vector
gadgets together in
sequences and it won't work and i'll try
to fix it it won't work again
we'll fix it again and then in the end
it will work okay
so here's the attempt so the first
attempt is
i take my my
gadgets for the first sequence and i put
them
one next to the other f of s1 f of s 2 f
of s n
i take the other ones also put them next
to each other but i also
add this extra stuff on the left and on
the right
which is just the gadget for the all
one's vector repeated n
minus one times in both cases okay so
this is just the first idea
so why do i do this
well the idea is sort of this is what we
want
what we want is well if uh
if there is no pair of orthogonal
vectors and if you think
just think of these gadgets as just
being one one simple which is not going
to happen but
assume for a moment that they are and
if if uh there's no s by and s
j such that they're um
such that they're orthogonal then all of
them are non-orthogonal so i can just
so no matter how i align f of s i with g
of s j
i always get beta so the most i can get
is n times beta
this is some heuristic argument now
if if on the other hand there's some
pair
f of sr some s i and some sj that are
orthogonal
then i can align f of s i with g of s j
to get beta plus one
and i can align everything before it
with the gadgets for the all ones vector
and everything after it to the gadgets
of the s
one vectors of the ones vector again
so this part here the green stuff will
give me
n minus 1 times beta and i'll get beta
plus 1
from the alignment of sine x j this is
the idea
okay so again if
if my solutions always happen to match
an f a gadget of of the f-type to a
gadget of the g-type
then this will happen so then if there
are no orthogonal vectors they will get
an
and beta and if there are you will get
something bigger
now of course there's a problem because
often no longer some
common subsequence doesn't necessarily
align this with this it may just sort of
align various symbols
with different gadgets so we need to
just
disallow this okay
so let's try attempt to
again we assume we have these nice
vector gadgets and whenever
two vectors are orthogonal you get
something bigger than beta when they're
not to get beta
now what we'll do now is we'll take
q to be zero repeated q little q
time so zero is some letter that didn't
appear anywhere else
we'll take r to be one to the q again
one repeated two times
one didn't appear anywhere else and what
we'll do is
around every gadget i'll put a q and an
r
so what does this achieve
well first we have to prove some lemon
which i'm not going to prove to you
and dilemma says that if at any point
one of the zeros of a q
is aligned with a zero here then we
might as well have aligned the whole
block
of zeros to the whole block of the zeros
below
so we have to prove this and require
some thought but
you can do this and then the same
happens if uh
one of the ones of an r is a match to
one of the ones here might as well have
matched the whole block
so is it sorry if you're saying like if
you match one bit of one q in
x with another bit of another q in y
then you might as well match the entire
cube
exactly that is exactly what i'm saying
i'm saying if if one of the
one of the letters in one of the queues
here is matched to one of the letters of
this queue here
then i might as well have matched all
the letters of the two cubes
so okay so now we can assume this it
depends on what q is we will set
this little q to be big enough in order
for this happen but
assume that this is the case yeah little
q will be big
so again we pick cubic
okay and now what happens is not not
only this is this lemma true
but also all the q's and
r's of x must be matched to a y
and this is because if some
q is not matched to something in y
then we pick this little q so big that
we lost
q alignments here but we and we cannot
make them up
by even if all of the f's and g's
were matched to each other so
this is the idea so we pick
this little q to be so big in terms of
what's the maximum alignment between
an f and a g and and now
we enforce that all the q's and r's of x
are matched to
something in y all right so now
what we get immediately we get that
there is no
g sub k that's aligned with more than
one of the f's
because if it's a line with more than
one of the f's then we'll miss one of
the r's and q's in the middle
so so in one direction we're fine
right so this means that each of the g
sub of s are mapped to a single
f but they're now but now there could be
multiple g's that are aligned with
the single f so we haven't fixed that
problem
so the solution might align
f of s sub i would start with several g
suppressive case and okay so now
we're we have a problem again and we try
to fix it
okay um
the capital q's and rs of x are all
matched
so all the capital q's and r's of x are
matched to some q's and r's and y
but it could be that this one is matched
to this q but r
is mapped to far away r
yeah y has more keys in ours because i
added these and
mine minus ones over here and just to
make sure f
and g never map to zero or one then up
to five and seventeen and something like
that
yeah zeros and ones are letters that do
not appear anywhere else they only
appear in q and r
yeah so now okay so now what we have
actually achieved is
uh that all the g sub g's over here
they're partitioned into these blocks
where they're matched
where they're aligned with at most the
single f
okay so we have these blocks and this
helps us actually
here's the final attempt and i think
this one works
so now what we do we pick a p
p is uh some
p is this which is a letter two doesn't
that doesn't appear anywhere else
repeated r times and r is big
but it's smaller than q okay
so now what i do is i put
p repeated the length of y times over
here
and p repeated the length of y times on
the left as well
this only at most you know triples the
length of x
so okay
good uh and on top of that after each r
i put a p
and a p at the very beginning okay so
why would i want to do this
so what i achieve is putting these p's
because this the length of p is actually
smaller than the length of q and r
suitably chosen how small it is
we still get the property that every q
and r of
x is matched to some q and r of y
but after we have done that because the
length of p is still big
uh we want as many of the p's to be
matched to the
as many of the p's of y to be matched to
x
okay and what does that mean
well uh look at look at how the q's and
r's were matched
over here q's and r's of x were matched
down here
what happened is that the ps that are
between these green lines cannot
be matched anywhere in x because the
only p's in x are on the outside
so when we when we do this alignment
and every q and r of x is matched we
lose
n minus one of the piece
okay but if we happen to align
whenever i line a q the r is matched
right
right here and whenever i align a q its
r is matched right after it after the g
then we'll only lose n minus one of the
piece
which is exactly you know the minimum we
can lose
and and because we made p very big this
will
this will actually happen in the longest
common subsequent solution
okay so exactly n minus one of the ps
in y are matched and n also
every f f of sub i will be fully aligned
with some g
of s sub j possibly the all one string
because
maybe you aligned it here all right
okay questions
you need to be slightly careful because
this q and
r cannot be too big because it can be
only polynomial in d you cannot depend
on m
yes because
somebody's like to take a number n like
q equal to and and
then we work except we'll blow up your
strengths yes
but then the arguments with islam is a
little bit more careful
yes that's why i said that you don't get
a full proof uh
you have to be careful yes all of these
p q's and
r's have to be polynomial and d and they
are and you have to show that things
still work when they're short
so the dilemma requires
more work so essentially if you
if you have a mapping of one too many of
the
let's say from the top to the bottom
then you are skipping an entire
pe yes and you don't have
what enough of them you don't get enough
of the
from the f and g alignments you don't
get enough to make up for this entire p
that you get you got
okay so what you can gain extra let's
say by making
by mapping pieces of the y thing to
different to x is not enough
to justify the loss of one single p
right exactly exactly it's not enough to
uh make up for the loss of a single p
and you have to show that this still
happens when p is probably logarithmic
and d
but you can not poly logan polynomial
okay or logarithmic making them so
yes so now what we've achieved is that
we actually have an alignment of the f
sub
of the sis and sj's exactly
uh and because i i only put n minus ones
here
n minus one of the all ones vectors here
and i minus one of the all ones vectors
here there will be
some massive by this is mapped to one of
the subjs
so let's talk about the length of the
longest common subsequence
you will get two n times p
from aligning the piece because
you lose n minus one ps but will you
align all of the
p's in y and how many p's and y are left
we let's say n minus 1 are lost and then
you count the rest
this is n and then this is n plus 1 and
this is n minus 1 so you get 2n
so 2 np comes from aligning all of the
p's from y
n times q plus r is
the cost from aligning all the q and r's
of x
and you can check that there's n of them
and then the rest comes from aligning
uh as size with sj's possibly some of
the sj's
as zeros and then
uh what you get is that if there is no
orthogonal pair the entire contribution
of the red part
is n times beta because there's only n
of the f
f sub s of i's and each one is aligned
with exactly one
g of s of j and if there is an
orthogonal pair you get an extra plus
one
because in the position where you put an
s and sj and you align them
you you get beta plus one instead of it
okay so
this would be the reduction if we
actually had the vector gadgets
how big is beta compared to
these other scores uh so
beta um you'll see in a moment
and i'll give you better okay any more
questions
so now we know what to do the moment
someone gives us vector gadgets
and now we have to construct the vector
gadgets
um so before that i think i already said
all of these quantities will be
polynomial and d so we're fine with the
length of the strings there n times poly
d
and now we'll construct these
the vector gadgets
similar to what we did before we'll now
assume we have
coordinate gadgets and we'll construct
these in the end so what's a chord in a
gadget
it there are two functions that take
a bit zero one and create a sequences
and the sequence is their sequence of c
and e
and the sequences have this property
that the longest common subsequence of c
of x and e of y is zero
if both x the both both the bits are one
and
it's one otherwise so if
unless you if you get one and one you
get a zero
contribution to the longest common
subsequence and you get a one
if there's one zero zero one or zero
zero
this is very nice because uh when you
take
uh inner products this is exactly
uh what you care about when you when you
get a one and a one
one and one sequence one and one vector
and one in the other
you get that they're not orthogonal this
is when you want
the longest common subsequence to be to
be small
so okay so let's assume that somehow we
get these coordinate gadgets
and that they're very very short so
they're sequences of like two
we'll see this in a bit so now assuming
that we have them
we're going to create the vector gadgets
and it's kind of a
similar way to what we did before we're
going to pick a letter
5 which doesn't appear anywhere else
and a letter 3 that doesn't appear
anywhere else
we'll pick the number of repetitions of
3 to be
this exact quantity where you is the
number of fives in each block
so we'll you'll see why i picked this in
a second you don't have to care about it
right now
but the idea what's the idea
so there's two ways to align these
things
either you align some three to some
three
in which case you cannot align any of
the the other stuff with each other
if you line a three with a three you
have to align the entire
three blocks to the entire three block
and you only get a contribution of r
to the long x comma subsequence
okay oh i should do and then
also again we can show this lemma
because of the choice of views and r's
that if you ever match
two fives then the entire blocks
are matched together the same length as
before
and what i just said is that if any
three is matched from here to there
then no other symbols no other non three
symbols are matched
and all the three is r and the let and
the length is r
now what happens if the threes are not
matched then we match
this this other portion with this other
portion here
and then we set this up
so that all the fives must be matched if
you lose a single five
then you lose an entire block of u5's
and if you lose an entire block of u5's
the length of the longest common
subsequence will be too small
it will be d times u
because so originally we had d plus one
uh
blocks of five if we lose one of them we
only have
uh d of them and then we get d times u
of them
the contribution of the rest of the
subsequence is at most two times d
because uh the the these
little subsequent these coordinate
gadgets was of length two
and so uh even if we match all of them
we only get 2d
and so in the end we get something
that's less than r uh by our choice
there
so we if no three is matched all of the
fives have to be
and if we match every single one of the
fives then they have to be matched like
this
and this means that the alignment is of
these c's and this
is like exactly as in the vector vector
world
and we'll and if we have the coordinate
gadgets then immediately we get
uh what do we get we get that the
either the longest common subsequences
are
whenever the vectors are not orthogonal
or it's more than or otherwise
and it's more there are because you get
you get this plus one
what happens before well
you'll see it in the next slide
good questions you're paying attention
yeah the letters are from zero to six so
we're missing four and six right now
so we'll see four and six on the next
slide
i know okay finally we get we have to do
the coordinate gadgets uh
oh what am i doing here oh yeah i had to
tell you that if all
fives are matched then for every t we
have a matching between c
of s i of t and c of s i of
s j of t that should be a j and
oops and that's an e so e and j
that's all you have to go that way
and so this is an e here too okay
sorry about that and so you what you get
again is what i said is that
uh you get d plus one times u plus d
minus one of r
and we get less than that if they're not
orthogonal but if they are
you're going to get extra one okay
i said this before okay so if if they
are a target no you get that all the
fives are mentioned they're d plus one
times u
of them and you get d from every single
one of these matches because they are
all zero one one zero or zero zero
okay so this immediately gives us the
longest common subsequences
are if they're not orthogonal and it's
at least r plus one otherwise
okay coordinate gadgets uh
what do we want we want these gadgets c
and e
says that whenever the two bits are one
you get the the longest common sequence
is zero
of length zero and otherwise you get a
one so there they are
okay so c of zero is four
six c of 1 is 4 e of 0 is 6 4
e of 1 is 6. you notice that e of 1 and
c
of 1 have a longest common subsequence
of 0
and all the others have a 1 of 1.
and they're they're very short
so so this is it then i'll give you a
little bit of a conclusion and
we'll
okay so the recap of the reduction we
use coordinate gadgets to make vector
gadgets we use
extra symbols to enforce cooperation
and then we use vector gadgets to make
these sequences again using extra
symbols
to make them cooperate
and this happens in all the reductions
okay so here's some extensions that
using the same type of reductions you
can
do first of all we don't need to start
from orthogonal vectors we can start
from something
that counts the number of coordinates in
which
uh how far you are from being orthogonal
in a sense
this also means you can make this thing
work under this slightly
maybe slightly more believable com
hypothesis that
you can't solve max k sat for okay
faster than two to the n times so there
for every epsilon there is
a case or that this happens
so maybe it's more believable uh you can
also prove this theorem
instead of taking two sequences you take
k of them and now you want to know the
longest common subsequence of all of
them
you can show that klcs cannot be solved
in this much time
and into the kl minus epsilon time under
the orthogonal vectors conjecture and
also this
is the alphabet size is order k
which is actually small there's no
dependence on n
that's nice and
bringman and kineman showed that our
alphabet size
was seven they showed you can bring it
down to two
we we thought we could do it too but it
required more work so
we didn't work on it that hard
okay so in conclusion
so all the reductions for for shaded
distance dynamic time are warping they
use similar ideas they have a similar
flavor
you do some you have some gadgets you
combine them in a clever way
and i think you can probably do it for
other sequence problems
so is there any hardness for
approximating these problems
we don't know how to do this uh so
carl did it for um for shade distance
but
for a longest common subsequence in edit
distance we don't know how to do it
because the reductions are
only about uh distinguishing between a
quantity and a quantity plus one
and then is there any sort of hardness
about getting some super logarithmic
speed up
maybe not maybe we can get more than
follow your great mix soon
i don't know so those are my main two
questions about sequences and this
concludes my talk so thanks
yeah do you think there's any hope of
showing a sequence between them or
of reductions between them ah it's a
great question is there some equivalence
between them
maybe i i haven't worked very hard on it
but it sounds
like a good problem yeah
um
so our results imply some w1 hardness
when the
when the alphabet sizes are the case so
that wasn't quite it wasn't known it was
known that
it's it's very hard when you allow the
alphabet to be really big
so what is the best appreciation for hcs
when you allow linear time
you don't know anything about this
probably not matches now the second
question may be silly about what is
known
if you want to walk k dogs
i'm not sure do you know carl
it probably depends on how you hook the
dogs up
read the simple simple way right
yeah that's the point is it the star or
are they on a line or
you can actually have a box in the graph
probably right
a random dog walk okay
good question
you might want sure you might want the
minimum with all the leashes
okay dogs you might want the minimum of
all leashes like if you have a button
you have so it's min max min
oh horror minifigures yeah okay
min relax sounds good but then
you could just do the pairwise
the sum of the pairwise distances or the
maximum of the pair of the distances
be some function of the distances no no
no i'm sorry
because you have to go on the same walk
the other dogs walk differently
yeah i think open problem i'll put it on
the slide k dogs
uh yeah okay
anymore yeah
this reduction now this reduction that
you presented is very
tight right in the sense that suppose
that you improve uh
the only orthogonal vector you go
you get n to 1.99 then you will get
exactly roughly the same up to polylog
factors right right
sorry so you get a faster algorithm
you you don't lose much here in the
reduction you essentially get the same
yeah because you do you have a single
instance so
and you only get a something that
depends on d
as the overhead so so the runtimes will
be roughly the same up to
poly d factors you change the the
constant right but
with these orthogonal vector reductions
you
you get this type of very tight i mean
this is
your experience sometimes you get very
tight and
usually it's because you only did one
one two you know
one string one is to one instance but
uh actually it's a good point i think
maybe maybe for the
approximation portion if you wanted to
show approximation hardness maybe you
need to do more instances
maybe it'll be nice please this type of
reduction doesn't
seem to do it but
thank you